what's going on everybody welcome to
part two of the highlight series
in this video what rumi going over is
how to go about improving your AI from
this point so I'm gonna kind of just go
through the pipeline process that I've
been doing to incrementally improve my
AI so first of all like I was saying in
the previous video it's fun to watch the
games that you've won but I tend to get
the most from the games that I lose and
if I do watch the games that I've won
actually I'm usually looking at why did
I win like why did the other person lose
pretty much I just like to look at why
are people losing so you can actually
learn a lot too from watching not just
your games but other people's games
especially better player games anyways
what I'm gonna do is just replay a game
here I'm the purple player here and
let's just kind of try to identify some
of the problems here so right out of the
gate one of the problems is all of our
ships are going to the exact same place
and also passing a lot of planets along
the way also we can see here like this
is a horrible example where let me just
go back a tiny bit like not only are we
behind we're not gonna win the race to
this planet why are all of our ships
going to this same exact planet that's
kind of a problem and then basically
we're losing battles with other ships
we've gotten ourselves loan up and then
there we've been totally eliminated but
at least right out of the gate you know
even in the beginning - we passed a lot
of good planets or so you know we're
just trying to head to the center which
is not the greatest idea but really we
just need to pick maybe one or two
things that we want to improve for now
see how we did and then continue to
improve from there so I'm gonna go ahead
and change a couple things one thing I
guess really I'm gonna change one thing
but because we're changing one thing we
want to change one more thing and that
is first of all our ships are headed to
the exact same planet instead let's say
we want to make all of our ships head to
unique planets now if we're gonna do
that the next thing that we want to go
ahead and do is right now all of our
ships are traveling at half speed let me
go ahead and just open up the AI so you
can see so this is the script
for our AI again this is the exactly
this is just the starter but there's
nothing else I've changed yet if we
scroll on down to the speeds that we're
traveling at it's always at like the max
speed divided by 2 what we want to do is
probably stop doing that as well as long
as our ships are going in different
directions we're not so likely to run
into ourselves so let's go ahead and
just get rid of that as well and let's
see what kind of change that makes for
us so let's just say right now we are
ranked twenty two thousand three hundred
and forty six let's make these edits and
see how our rank changes so to begin
what I'm gonna go ahead and do is so so
when we submit like I was saying before
it always has to be called in title case
you know my bot PI so generally what I
do when I create new versions is I'll
just copy them paste the old version and
then I'll rename one of them to be my
bot - v1 right so that's v1 and then
I'll edit the new one which we've
actually already got it up and then I'll
just call it settler v2 right because
that's v2 so so that's like the changes
I'll make in the directory now what we
need to do is also if we're gonna use
this bat what we're gonna do is edit
that and then we need to not only run my
bot but now we need to run my bot in v1
I'm actually just gonna manually run
this command so it doesn't go away but
you could also run the bat anyway it's
not important but make sure you make
those edits now what we're gonna do is
I'm gonna move this aside and like I
said let's go ahead and modify the speed
first so max speed / - lets just not
divide by two and then do we travel
anywhere else no so it's just in that
one spot that we're gonna go ahead and
change so so we're gonna divide by two
there and then let's go ahead and make
sure they don't all go to the same
planet so the way that we're gonna do
that is just let's just make a list so
planned underscore planets and for now
that just starts as an empty list now if
our ship decides to go to one of these
planned planets we just need to add
so we're gonna do is we're gonna come
down here for ship basically here if the
ship is docked we just skip it and then
we start iterating over these planets if
the planet is owned then we're gonna
skip that planet if the plant if the
ship can dock at the planet well we want
to dock otherwise we're traveling to the
planet and this is where the problems
happening it's when many many many ships
are travelling the same planet that's
causing trouble for us so in here in
this else this is where we're gonna add
kind of our new logic and that's going
to be first of all we're going to just
start by saying if the planet is in our
planned planets we basically just want
to skip this planet and continue to the
next planets so we're just gonna say
continue now otherwise else we're gonna
run this so let me just ask that over
there and now what we want to do is if
if we do start navigating to this planet
basic at this point once we've added it
to the command queue you know it's a
plan so so let's go ahead and add it so
we're gonna say plan to underscore
planets dot append and we're gonna
append the planet so once we've done
that that's we're just gonna make those
two tiny changes I think for now let's
go ahead and save that I'm gonna close
out and what we want to do is first
let's go ahead and run this I'm gonna
run it with so I'm going to go to this
address bar here hit CMD and we actually
could just run run game dot bat like
that runs through all the turns and then
we basically get to see okay what
happened at the very end actually these
are all being called settler v2 that's
kind of problematic why did that happen
so they're v2 and then this one should
have been
why did that happen did this not get
edited possibly oh I didn't I guess I
didn't save the edit that I made
I see anyway I'll just copy the command
let's run that one more time
copy paste run it okay
so similar v2 came in ranked one let's
just run it one more time
settler v2 came in ranked one no time
for a good measure
yep southerly v2 comes in rank one okay
we're pretty confident that's good but
let's go ahead and check a replay real
quick let's just make sure that we
haven't made any serious mistakes so v2
is our purple sure enough he's going to
unique planets every time we just ran
into ourselves that's problematic
we're also traveling pretty fast let's
speed it up so he's getting planets and
all that but yeah we've definitely
secured our victory at this point okay
cool
looking good looking good let's go ahead
and submit it so what we're gonna do is
take my bot pie the highlight part are
the HLT directory we're gonna go ahead
and send to compressed and we'll call
this mission to zip and submit a bot and
yeah just drag that in there so this
just tells you you want to pay attention
to the version number so we'll submit
the bot because you can see here in this
old replay it was on v6 so now we're
gonna be curious about v7 so it says
what we'll play within those 15 minutes
but like I said before it's usually
pretty darn quick I wouldn't even be
surprised if this one since this is at
the same minute mark let's see if that
still v6 let's go back
so actually were ranked 2403 right now
surprise I hasn't played any more games
anyway I'm gonna go ahead and pause the
recording now wait a few minutes and
then I'll start back up and we'll kind
of see how how we've been doing okay at
this point it's been about only only
about three minutes and at least the
last v6 game I played I was ranked
around 2500 and we've already dropped to
20 256 but that's probably gonna be
pretty volatile for the next probably
while so yeah 22 74 as you can see we're
making quite a few victories I think
that'll this will probably continue to
fall I was hoping to see that we would
maybe even breach the 2000s but you know
get into actually really the one
thousands but let's see why we lost
various games and also why we won
various games so let's go ahead and
check out a couple in fact let me just
sorry I I think I still had an old one
up I just don't want to get confused so
this is a game that we've won I believe
and we actually blew ourselves up I
think initially there but as you can see
first of all these other players are
travelling very slow so probably one of
the major reasons why we're winning
right now is we're travelling very fast
and they just blew themselves up
basically and we ran into them too I
guess but yeah unfortunately we've lost
ships up again so that's probably why we
lost so it's a major issue that needs to
probably be addressed we almost beat
them to that planet bomber and then
we're just spawning ships so right away
I can see probably what we want to do is
start attacking like if we just attacked
this one guy we could steal this planet
and we probably could have stolen this
planet by now obviously there's a bunch
of ships but even if we scroll back kind
of initially we could have started
attacking this planet this planet we
could definitely taking this one so a
lot of these ships I'm sorry our planets
would have been super easy to take over
at this point
okay let's refresh again just kind of
see where we are now okay yeah so we now
we are in 1974 so we're slowly still
improving our rank this is the highest
rank you've ever achieved
this is the rank you are right now so
I'm actually not even sure how this one
got achieved this is a new account so it
must have been like a really temporary
rank like sometimes you might initially
win a bunch of games and your rank will
get really good and then you'll actually
finally settle it at a certain number
I'm gonna wager this was a fluke because
actually like we saw before even when I
uploaded this one my rank was actually
going up I think I hit like a 2600 I
think before it started going down again
so there's so much as to chance that you
know temporarily you might hit a really
high rank that you don't actually
deserve but over a long period of time
with the specific bye like you'll
definitely have a more realistic rank
but yeah so I rank is improving wow
we're already at 1800 not to just keep
refreshing we're doing very good so yeah
we have dropped a ton by just simply
going to a bunch of planets and
traveling at a high rate of speed okay
so we just made a couple of edits and
we've jumped a lot of ranks we might
even be able to jump over a thousand
ranks just with that change but we
immediately can see there are things for
us to improve even in the games that
we've we've won we just have all these
idol ships that should be doing
something they should either be mining
and producing more ships or they should
be attacking the other player so I think
the next steps I would do is start to
attack the enemy ships with our ships
and when we do that that means we can
actually open up other planets and then
we can basically steal that planet and
begin to mine it ourselves so like all
these ships could be attacking this guy
we could end the game but instead we're
always pretty much gonna go to 300 steps
unless we just happen to run into one of
them so anyways the next step I think
what we would take would be to start
attacking other players so anyways
that's all for now if you have any
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
I will see you in another video